wir rufen aus serbien
hier im dokumentarfilm neuland mit
produziert vom srf eine
integrationsschule in basel soll jungen
ausländern die neu in der schweiz sind
den start ins berufsleben ermöglichen
der lehrer christian zink arbeitet hier
seit 25 jahren
er hilft jugendlichen sich in ihrer
neuen heimat zurechtzufinden
die schwierigkeit aber komme ich danke
aber die große die allergrößte
schwierigkeiten trautner vertrag mit uns
akzeptiert ohne neues land neue kultur
ist warum die jungen menschen in die
schweiz kommen ist nur am rand thema des
films die meisten sind unfreiwillig hier
belastet mit schwierigen
lebensgeschichten alle verbindet die
hoffnung auf ein besseres leben
doch in der schweiz sind sie fremd die
sprache ein ständiger hürdenlauf die
joker waren sehr hoch vor sich verzählt
war eine szene für das buch ist aber
eine abstrakte spruch zum schluss druck
denn wie sie um wort ringe und sprachlos
war und irritiert uhr und ihrem schmerz
ka-news druck können haben sie für den
krieg gedichte geschrieben und gegen den
krieg produkte über den film oft wird
der lehrer dann wie hier bei nase zum
seelentröster und ringt selbst und
passende worte
sie sind in die schweiz gekommen weil
ihre mutter gestorben ist
das thema einwanderung beschäftigt die
regisseurin anatomen schon lange als sie
christian zink kennenlernt wird die idee
zu einem film konkret
die baslerin ist beeindruckt von seinem
großen engagement für junge migranten
die anforderungen für den berufseinstieg
sind hoch zink bereitet die schüler
darauf vor zeigt ihnen aber auch die
grenzen des machbaren auf ich weiß nicht
ob sie genug schulwesen im moment sehe
ich diesen weg nicht verschieben
die träume der realität anpassen
auch das ist migration
bereit seien zu lernen angefangen bei
einfachen verhaltensregeln und es gibt
kultur durch gnade das unhöflich und
respektlose stark machen
und wenn man das nicht thematisiert dem
können unserer schülerinnen und schüler
spielerinnen firma und wartet dort als
unhöflich taxiert bis ist aber nicht
klientel sido begrenzt aber ich weiß
wenn christian zink die jungen leute auf
ihrem weg gebracht hat heißt es abschied
nehmen
neuland der für den schweizer filmpreis
nominiert ist ist ein film der uns die
menschen hinter dem wort migration näher
bringt und er uns außerdem einen
menschen zeigt der mit seinem einsatz
bewegt